pavan je vous propose de découvrir avec
nous une séquence spéciale consacrée à
l'un des hommes non pas politique et là
il n'y aura pas de combat d'idées mais
un combat musical l'un des hommes qui
fait la une de l'actualité en matière de
pop music
c'est david bowie
le talent est là
merci
pas de fête
je sais
c'est une autre histoire vous savez moi
je t'ai toujours du milieu artistique
grandi là dedans j'ai dansé et fait des
tonneaux de cinq à huit ans
et après je suis resté dans ce milieu du
jour et je l'aimé bien pour travailler
pour les artistes tuerie artis pas alors
là je croyais pour les gens du spectacle
c'est comme ça que j'ai connu des
artistes complets
n'est ce pas donc j'ai beaucoup d'amis
en angleterre et c'est comme ça qu'une
fois j'ai eu la chance de voir david
parce que ceux qui m'ont invité me
sortait à londres alors david et terrain
toujours nadoris par courrier du tout
quand j'ai lu la première fois jouer
il était vraiment adoré ça je m'en
souviens mais pas tellement comme un
musicien plutôt comme un écolier voyez
pour le terreau artistes
il faut évidemment du métier nom n'est
pas artiste pour ça on est triste quand
on a une petite flamme au soir et cette
fois il l'avait déjà alors j'ai cru en
lui et puis il était très beau et très
sincère
matthew et j'ai l'impression que c'est à
partir de cet âge qui se produisaient
déjà dans les petits groupes amateurs
tous est on indiqué rue d'une douzaine
d'instruments
stationnaire et l'eire qui changent
comme sa personnalité de maquillage
considérez-vous aujourd'hui comme un
artiste ou un homme d'affaires un
artiste mais je dis à tout le monde que
je suis un homme d'affaires un corner
moi je suis un fantaisiste
il y des lices il voudrait la libération
il voudrait la justice c'est ce qu'il a
cherché par exemple ces recherches de
bouddhisme scélérat chardy donc de
justice et trouve que le monde est
hypocrite alors libéralisation
des connaissances
e
à
la vague rose
et ce fan club en france alors comment
vous l'avez créée donc il y avait des
enfants de mes clientes il y avait des
enfants de côté crise qui le faisait qui
était passionné de la musique pop rock
alors par exemple je leur ai passé des
vieux disques
n'est ce pas elles se sont passionnés
pour ça alors il y avait déjà un noyau
ans bien avant le groupe
spagnuolo d'amis que je connaissais bien
qu'ils venaient me voir hier quand le
fan club a démarré on a commencé à en
écrire d'abord tu peux puis ça a pris
des proportions terrible et vous savez
ça fait vraiment beaucoup pour les
jeunes ils ont besoin de 30 heures
il ya un grand amour frontère
fraternelles entre eux malgré les
différences sociales intellectuelles du
spo niveau de vie sans suite
ce salon
c'est très fraternelle est vraiment
dimon activistes tués
on doit être quelque chose 4006 et pas
plus maintenant
le choix revient
pgo des gens qui m'aiment bien
je ne pense pas que ce soit moi d'en
parler
ce
m
dans ce sens
ils représentent les années 70 il
travaille
quand
pacy
enfin
man
merci natacha merci david bowie pour
cette interview exclusive pour tf1 si
vous voyez david bowie ailleurs à la
télévision ce soir de la seconde main ça
c'était de la première david bowie qui
n'a pas l'habitude de beaucoup parler
mais qui a accordé à jean claude
emmanuel qui a fait ce très beau
reportage avec toute l'équipe technique
qui l'entouraient et qui a accordé une
interview pour vous